I was talking to Sofia Bush earlier we
were talking about you and she said one
of the things that makes you so
inspiring to her is is the fact that you
are at the table you have a seat at the
table and a decision-maker and and
seeing a woman do that in Hollywood and
being at her best doing it is so
inspiring is that a legacy that you
think about you have to leave for your
little girls I think everything is
motivated by wanting to take care of
your children and carve a path for them
and leave them with a sense of morality
and dignity and responsibility and
accountability so I'm just I mean I grew
up with a very opinionated strong mother
who was very educated and who wanted her
girls this to of us in the family I had
a sister who wanted us to have
opportunities and I suppose that's the
great thing is being able to create
other opportunities for other women and
for the next generation you announced
they're gonna be on season two a big
little lies do they just have a brief
cameo or do they get to talk great you
will not say them you're gonna love it
you're so nice this is Monterey we pound
people with knives to death I know you
don't do this for the accolades but to
have your peers say we see you and we
recognize the work that you put in what
does that mean it's incredibly
validating but it's also feels you know
I want to keep going I want to be able
to keep throwing my my support of my
voice behind the things that I'm
passionate about and it kind of gives
you the opportunity to keep doing that
and so I suppose it's almost like Ford
momentum I just always wanted to act
since I was a little girl always and it
wasn't wasn't we're how it was more just
I needed to I needed to
and I started at school I went to drama
school and I've just continued on the
path and it's led me it's led me to the
most wonderful places and it's given me
so much joy
[Music]